Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik seguro
que os habéis dado cuenta de que hay un tema que
siempre nos ha gustado especialmente: el petróleo.
[Bueno, y también la Argentina, eso ya lo sabéis]
El caso es que el crudo sigue teniendo una
enorme influencia en la política internacional.
Por eso cada vez que se descubren grandes
yacimientos nuevos resulta emocionante,
especialmente si estos se producen en países
en vías de desarrollo o en países que, digamos,
no han sido famosos precisamente
por sus recursos energéticos.
Ese suele ser el preámbulo de muchas historias
políticas y también económicas. Nos encanta.
Precisamente este fue el caso de
un país relativamente desconocido
y poco poblado del que ya os hemos hablado varias
veces aquí en VisualPolitik. Por
supuesto, estoy hablando de Guyana.
La misma Guyana que ahora se enfrenta
al desafío de la Venezuela bolivariana
por el control del Esequibo.
Sin embargo, en esta ocasión
no os vamos a hablar de Guyana, sino de
su aún menos conocido vecino: Surinam.
Para muchos, el país más prometedor de 2024.
Situado entre la Guyana, la Guyana Francesa y
Brasil, este país cuyo territorio está cubierto
en un 90% por la selva amazónica es uno de los
más pequeños de Sudamérica y también el menos
poblado: tan solo tiene unos 600.000 habitantes.
Surinam, que fue primero avistada por Cristóbal
Colón en 1498 y colonizada por holandeses a
partir de 1667, es un país que normalmente
siempre ha pasado más bien desapercibido.
Digamos que no tiene una posición
geoestratégica particularmente relevante,
no tiene una economía desarrollada, y tampoco
cuenta con recursos de gran importancia…
O al menos eso ha sido así.. ¡Hasta ahora!
Y es que, veréis, hace tan solo unos años Surinam
pasó de ser un total desconocido a estar en el
punto de mira mundi al después de esta noticia:
N1 (7 de enero de 2020: Total y
Apache anuncian un "importante"
hallazgo de petróleo en aguas de Surinam. FT)
Desde entonces, este país ha estado en el radar
tanto de grandes petroleras como de muchas
grandes potencias. ¿Por qué? Pues porque con
los descubrimientos realizados, el oro negro
con burbujas de Surinam puede convertirse en
uno de los más lucrativos del mundo.
Hoy la industria espera que Surinam
pueda seguir los exitosos pasos de Guyana y
convertirse en un importante proveedor de crudo,
lo que dada su escasa población podría
convertirlo en un país inmensamente rico.
Queridos amigos, ¿cómo ha llegado
Surinam hasta este punto? ¿Por qué
se están depositando tantas esperanzas en este
pequeño y desconocido país? ¿Puede el conflicto
por la Guayana Esequiba perturbar sus planes?
Pues bien, ya sabéis, gasolina y arranquemos.
[Por cierto, si os gustan todos estos temas
no os podéis perder Si lo Hubiera Sabido,
el canal de información financiera de
Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Por ejemplo, en el último vídeo os contamos cómo
Irlanda se ha hecho rica y también qué problema
existe con sus cifras de crecimiento, que ya
os adelanto están adulterados. También hemos
hablado mucho de petróleo, gas y energía. No os
lo perdáis. Os dejo el link en la descripción.]
Dicho esto continuemos.
T1 (SURINAM: JOVEN Y TURBULENTA)
Desde el comienzo de Surinam como país plenamente
independiente en noviembre de 1975, esta excolonia
holandesa no ha tenido una historia realmente
fácil. La situación del país, como también
ocurrió en su vecina Guyana, era devastadora,
con una enorme pobreza y una economía muy poco
productiva, poco desarrollada y basada casi
exclusivamente en la exportación de minerales.
La situación era tal que tan solo 5
años después de su independencia en
1980 ocurrió lo que suele ocurrir en estos
casos: se produjo un golpe de Estado.
Y, con ello, llegó al poder la que es,
seguramente, la figura más importante
de la historia política de esta joven
nación: Desi Bouterse. [Dési Báuterse]
Jefe del Consejo Militar Nacional tras
el golpe de Estado, Bouterse prometió
la vuelta de la democracia para 1982.
Sin embargo, sin señales de que eso fuera
a suceder, ese mismo año miles de manifestantes
tomaron las calles y se enfrentaron al régimen
militar que decidió ejecutar a 15 manifestantes
opositores. Tras esto, toda la ayuda financiera
proveniente de Países Bajos y Estados Unidos
quedó suspendida inmediatamente, lo que supuso
un golpe de gracia para el país. La economía de
Surinam se quedó estancada duramente mucho tiempo.
Las tensiones sociales y económicas llegaron
a tal punto que, en 1985, Bouterse accedió a
comenzar el camino hacia el regreso de la
democracia, algo que se culminó en 1987.
Sin embargo, el exdictador, que debía de echar de
menos el poder, volvió a dar un golpe de Estado en
1990. Eso sí, este segundo periodo dictatorial
solo duró apenas unos pocos meses, y en mayo
de 1991 s e volvieron a celebrar elecciones tras
las presiones de Estados Unidos y Países Bajos.
Desde entonces, la democracia se ha mantenido
estable. Sin embargo, no se puede decir
exactamente lo mismo de su economía.
Como podéis ver, todo empezó a cambiar
con el nuevo siglo. A partir del año 2001
comenzó el superciclo de las materias primas:
Es decir, el alza de precios de las
materias primas. Algo por lo que, Surinam,
al igual que ocurrió con sus vecinos
sudamericanos, se vio muy beneficiado.
No obstante, la época de bonanza llegó a su
fin en 2015 y Surinam volvió a chocarse con la
dura realidad: la minería, su principal actividad
económica, no era suficiente para salir adelante.
Sin embargo, ese mismo año llegó una
noticia que dio un vuelco de 180 grados
a las esperanzas de este olvidado país:
N2 (20 de mayo de 2015) ExxonMobil anuncia
un importante descubrimiento de petróleo
frente a las costas de Guyana. ExxonMobil)
Ya desde el siglo XVIII se sabía que había
hidrocarburos en la cuenca de Guyana-Surinam,
pero nunca se había hallado una cantidad
significativa. Como os podéis imaginar,
una vez que el oro negro brotó en Guyana,
el siguiente objetivo iba a ser Surinam,
y de esta forma las exploraciones
pronto comenzaron en 2016.
Surinam no era un país nuevo en lo
que se refiere a la exploración y
explotación de petróleo. Ya en 1982 comenzó
a producir sus primeros barriles. De hecho,
cuenta con 3 campos petroleros terrestres con
unas reservas de unos 1.100 millones de barriles
que explota su petrolera estatal: Staatsolie.
No obstante, esos campos y pozos quedarían
a la altura del betún a partir de todo
lo que se comenzó a descubrir en 2020.
Atentos.
T2 (LA ESPERANZA PETROLERA)
2020 fue un año clave para Surinam, y no solo
porque también tuvo que hacer frente a la
Covid-19 y porque el exdictador Bouterse perdió
las elecciones tras 10 años en la presidencia.
2020 fue clave para Surinam porque
por fin se encontraron los primeros
grandes yacimientos petroleros en sus aguas.
Los gigantes petroleros Apache y Total Energies
encontraron las primeras señales de grandes
reservas petroleras. Desde entonces han encontrado
hasta 5 yacimientos en el bloque 58, con unas
reservas estimadas, solo en estos yacimientos,
de unos 6.500 millones de barriles de petróleo.
Una locura si tenemos en cuenta que el país solo
tiene unos 600 mil habitantes. Pensad que
teniendo en cuenta el yacimiento terrestre,
hablamos de unos 12.500 barriles de reservas
de crudo per capita. Hablamos, por tanto,
de unos beneficios potenciales de más de 550
mil dólares por cabeza. Una cantidad que la
mayor parte iría a parar a las arcas públicas.
Pero eso no es todo, la historia aún no ha
terminado. Otras empresas como Chevron,
Shell o la petrolera estatal de Malasia,
Petronas, también se han apuntando a esta
particular fiesta VIP y están explorando los
diferentes bloques de las aguas de Surinam.
¿Y sabéis qué? Cada una de ellas están
consiguiendo nuevos y jugosos descubrimientos.
Así que como os podéis imaginar, en Surinam están
pletóricos con todo esto. Creen que realmente
podrán replicar el milagro económico de Guyana.
Para los que no lo recordéis, Guyana cuenta con
unas reservas declaradas de 11.000 millones de
barriles en sus yacimientos submarinos,
yacimientos que le han permitido ser la
economía que más rápido ha crecido desde 2022. De
hecho , algunos analistas señalan que para 2040,
Guyana podría recaudar hasta $160.000 millones.
Una cantidad equivalente a 200 mil dólares por
habitante tan solo en los próximos 17 años
y eso sin tener en cuenta el resto de la
actividad econó mica. Una auténtica barbaridad.
No obstante, por el momento Surinam no cuenta
con unas reservas estimadas tan grandes como
las declaradas por Guyana. Pero con lo que sí
cuenta es con un presidente, Chan Santokhi, que
está ofreciendo unas condiciones que, se miren
por donde se miren, no se pueden rechazar.
Y es que veréis, ya desde el comienzo de su
mandato y los primeros grandes descubrimientos en
aguas de Surinam, Santokhi se ha centrado en hacer
del país un oasis para la inversión petrolera.
Por ejemplo, en vez de ofrecer acuerdos de
producción compartida de 20 años, como hacen
muchos de sus vecinos sudamericanos, los está
ofreciendo a 30 años, lo cual los hace mejores
para la inversión, la exploración y la producción.
Y, no solo eso, mientras las regalías por
ingresos de las empresas petroleras rondan el
16% de media a nivel internacional, Santokhi está
ofreciendo unas regalías de tan solo el 6.25%,
tan solo un poco más altas que en Guyana. Y,
por si fuera poco, el petróleo submarino de
Surinam es ligero y dulce, es decir, requiere de
menos dinero para conseguir un buen combustible.
Pues bien, todas estas condiciones hicieron
que, en septiembre de 2023, la petrolera
Apache confirmara que los yacimientos en el
bloque 58 serían rentables, de tal forma que,
junto a la francesa TotalEnergies, invertirán más
de 9.000 millones de dólares para poder empezar a
producir en el año 2028. Todo un pelotazo para una
economía fuertemente deprimida como la de Surinam.
El presidente Santokhi ha asegurado que
el dinero que se vaya a recaudar por los
contratos petroleros va a ir dirigido a la
tan necesaria diversificación de la economía:
C1 (“La existencia de petróleo y gas es
limitada, por lo que tenemos que usar los
ingresos para diversificar la economía, para
invertir en agricultura, en el sector turismo,
en vivienda, infraestructura… para un desarrollo
sostenible en el futuro” – Chan Santokhi,
presidente de Surinam, octubre 2022.)
Dicho de otra forma, el petróleo puede
convertirse en el fin del modelo económico que
ha dominado Surinam desde que era una colonia.
Por supuesto, además, Santokhi también
busca hacer frente a otros problemas:
como la pobreza en la que vive sumida la
mayor parte de la población del país o el
déficit fiscal crónico que ha llevado a que el
gobierno esté hundido en deudas y su moneda se
haya devaluado significativamente en los últimos
años. Por el momento, Santokhi ya ha logrado, con
las proyecciones petroleras en la mano, renegociar
la deuda de Surinam con algunos de sus acreedores:
N3 (Surinam sale de default con
una deuda vinculada al petróleo
de US$ 660 millones. Bloomberg)
Eso sí, esperad un momento antes
de lanzar las campanas al vuelo porque la
mayoría de los analistas alertan de dos
grandes amenazas que pueden echar por tierra
las grandes aspiraciones de los habitantes
de este pequeño y empobrecido país, ahora tan
emocionado con todo su oro negro con burbujas.
Prestad mucha atención.
T3 (EL PARÁSITO DE SURINAM)
Al igual que ha venido pasando en la próspera
Guyana, una sombra acecha también en Surinam,
la sombra de la corrupción.
Como sucede en otros muchos
países del continente americano, Surinam
es un país eminentemente corrupto.
Sí, es cierto, cuenta con algunas leyes para
luchar contra el fraude, el lavado de activos y
el contrabando. Sin embargo, todos esos esfuerzos
han resultado inútiles, simple y llanamente,
porque la figura política más importante del
país se ha lucrado con todo tipo de negocios
ilícitos. Hablamos, como no, del exdictador y
ahora expresidente Bouterse, que tiene a sus
espaldas más tramas que una serie de HBO.
Y es que, no hay duda, todos los analistas
concuerdan con que Bouterse convirtió
Surinam en su cortijo particular.
Utilizó todo el poder del Estado incluso para
lucrarse con sus negocios, en algunos casos
ligados al crimen organizado internacional.
Y es que, veréis, tras el fin de su segundo
gobierno militar en 1991, Bouterse comenzó a
construir su propio imperio criminal. Estoy
hablando del conocido como “Cartel Suri”, que se
centra en el tráfico de armas y de narcóticos.
De hecho, en 1999 fue condenado a 16 años
de prisión en Países Bajos por delitos de
narcotráfico y por el asesinato de 15 civiles en
1982. Bouterse es tan buscado que, a día de hoy,
no puede salir de Surinam, porque tiene una
orden internacional de arresto emitida por
la Europol. Pero no es el único que ha sido
juzgado por estos delitos: su hijo mayor,
Dino Bouterse, incluso fue apresado y condenado
en 2015 ni más ni menos que por este motivo.
Creo que os va a sorprender. Fijaos.
N4 (El hijo del líder de Surinam,
condenado a 16 años de cárcel en
EE.UU. por ayudar a Hezbolá. Reuters)
En general, Desi Bouterse supo aprovecharse
de las propicias condiciones para los
negocios ilícitos que Surinam ofrece.
Pensad que, estando cubierto en un 90% por
la densa selva amazónica, este país supone un gran
escondite para el crimen organizado. Además, su
población es pequeña y apenas cuenta con efectivos
policiales que controlen las fronteras de toda
esta vasta región, por lo que el tráfico de armas,
drogas y otros bienes es relativamente sencillo.
Y eso no es todo. La corrupción de Bouterse se
ha filtrado durante estos últimos 40 años en el
resto de las capas del Estado. ¿El resultado?
Hoy en Surinam el clientelismo y las coimas
a funcionarios son el pan nuestro de cada día.
De hecho, una de las principales razones por las
que estallaron protestas masivas de principios de
2023 fue precisamente esta enorme corrupción. Por
eso, la mayoría de los analistas, al igual que los
propios ciudadanos del país, temen que el dinero
del petróleo eeacabe mayormente en las manos
de los políticos y los funcionarios corruptos.
Es cierto, el presidente Santokhi está
intentando reforzar la lucha contra la
corrupción, pero la realidad es que, después
de 40 años parasitando el Estado, Bouterse
ha hecho que la tarea sea especialmente dura.
Y ojo, que esta no es esta la única amenaza a
los futuros ingresos o incluso a los
futuros planes petroleros del país.
Varios analistas apuntan a otra amenaza que tiene
que ver con el conflicto por la Guayana Esequiba.
N5 (El chavismo gana el referéndum
para la anexión del Esequibo y
eleva la tensión con Guyana. El País)
N6 (Venezuela recrudece el conflicto con
Guyana por el Esequibo y da un ultimátum a Exxon
y otros productores de petróleo. El Economista)
(Venezuela recrudece el conflicto con Guyana
por el Esequibo y da un ultimátum a Exxon y
otros productores de petróleo. El Economista)
El conflicto del Esequibo ha hecho saltar por
los aires la relativa estabilidad geopolítica de
la que gozaba el territorio. Tened en cuenta que,
si Venezuela llega a cumplir su
promesa y se anexiona el territorio,
Guyana perdería el 74% de su actual territorio.
Y a ver, parece poco probable que ocurra, pero,
¿qué queréis qué os diga? Con dictadores locos
y codiciosos nunca se sabe. En cualquier caso
los riesgos conviene tenerlos en cuenta.
Pues bien, aquí hay que tener en cuenta que,
aunque la mayoría de los pozos que le han dado
alas a la economía de Guyana no están en aguas
territoriales de la Guayana Esequiba, si
esta cayera en manos de Venezuela, Guyana
perdería importantes campos petroleros. En total,
perdería 3 de los 8 campos petroleros actuales,
y la mitad del más grande y fructífero
hasta el momento, el campo Stabroek.
Por eso, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, hay
quien se hace una pregunta: si Venezuela tomara el
Esequibo finalmente, ¿sería posible que Guyana
empezara a reclamar, o incluso a intentar tomar,
territorios de Surinam para compensar sus
pérdidas? En principio todo apunta a que no.
Las disputas territoriales marítimas en aguas
ricas en petróleo entre Guyana y Surinam ya
fueron resueltas en 2007. De hecho, el arbitraje
internacional dio un resultado mucho más favorable
a Guyana que a Surinam. Por lo tanto, Guyana no
podría reclamar aguas a Surinam. Y, ¿en cuanto a
territorio terrestre? Sí, es cierto, ambos países
mantienen una disputa territorial por una región
al sur de ambos países: la región del Tigri. Sin
embargo, la realidad es que Guyana controla este
territorio con sus tropas desde que incumplió
el acuerdo con Surinam de retirarlas en 1971.
Por lo tanto, Guyana no tendría ningún reclamo
legítimo ni sobre las aguas ni sobre ninguna
tierra de Surinam. De hecho, la realidad es
que, ahora mismo, no le convendría tener a
Surinam en su contra después de esta noticia:
N7 (Surinam apoya a Guyana en su conflicto
con Venezuela pese a problema
fronterizo bilateral. Swissinfo)
Sin embargo, lo qué si que podría ocurrir
es que los tambores de guerra en la región
frenen y ralenticen muchas inversiones, lo
que podría retrasar los sueños petroleros
de un país que puede convertirse en uno de
los más prometedores del mundo ya en 2024.
Así que, ya lo veis, todo apunta a que el
siguiente milagro económico se quedará en las
Guayanas, pero esta vez en Surinam. La excolonia
holandesa tiene por delante una oportunidad de
oro. Desde luego tiene tiempo para prepararse e
intentar corregir muchos de sus grandes problemas.
Al fin y al cabo los primeros barriles de los
nuevos campos no comenzarán a brotar hasta 2028.
Claro que, llegados a este punto, ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros: ¿creéis que
Surinam conseguirá replicar el éxito de su vecina
Guyana? ¿Qué creéis que deberían hacer frente a la
corrupción generalizada? ¿Es posible que las
grandes petroleras eviten el conflicto en el
Esequibo y en la región? Podéis dejarnos vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si
os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta pronto.